The runtime for It: Chapter Two has been revealed,
and it's a doozy.
Director Andy Muschietti confirmed to Digital
Spy that the It sequel clocks in at 2 hours
and 45 minutes.
A runtime that epic may send some moviegoers
with small bladders and restless legs running
for the hills, but Muschietti has promised
that the lucky few who have already seen It:
Chapter Two in test screenings haven't had
a single complaint about how long the film
is.
The director explained that the lengthy runtime
is simply the amount of time the story needed
in the long-awaited It follow-up, and the
extra 30 or so minutes in comparison to the
original were totally necessary.
Any other length would have meant dragging
the story out or clipping it too short.
"For 27 years, I dreamt of you."
Muschietti explained further:
"A movie is very different when you're writing
the script and you're building a story compared
to what the final product is.
At the beginning, when you're writing and
building the beats of the story, everything
that you put in there seems very essential
to the story.
However, when you have the movie finally edited
and it's four hours long, you realize that
some of the events and some of the beats can
be easily lifted but the essence of the story
remains intact.
You cannot deliver a four-hour movie because
people will start to feel uncomfortable, no
matter what they see, but we ended up having
a movie that is two hours and 45 minutes,
and the pacing is very good."
For those iron-bladdered viewers who actually
would love to see a four-hour version of It:
Chapter Two, you may not get to experience
such a thing in cinemas, but you'll surely
be able to watch it from the comfort of your
own home.
It: Chapter Two producer Barbara Muschietti
noted that there will most likely be a lengthier
director's cut of the film, presumably included
in a version of the film's home release.
She said:
"We will put out a director's cut because
this time it definitely merits it.
We have some amazing scenes that didn't make
it into the movie.
You have to make choices sometimes and some
things cannot be in this theatrical release
but are definitely worthy of people seeing
them at a later date."
But fear not, fright fans.
All the super-scary scenes are featured in
It: Chapter Two, not left for an alternate
cut.
Director Muschietti promised that, quote,
"...everything that is too scary is in the
movie," which we can assume are all those
horrifying scenes featuring a smarter, more
manipulative Pennywise the Dancing Clown,
and the sequence that features thousands of
gallons of fake blood to make what has been
reported to be the bloodiest scene in film
history.
The movie is also confirmed to include two
controversial storylines from the book: a
hate crime that wasn't included in the 1990
miniseries adaptation, and a domestic abuse
plot that was.
165 minutes is a pretty hefty runtime, but
it makes sense in context.
It: Chapter Two has a lot of ground to cover,
picking up 27 years after the events of the
first film to follow the grown-up Losers'
Club.
Considering it has to cover a huge swath of
Stephen King's more than 1,000-page novel,
it's kind of a wonder the filmmakers got away
with a runtime that came in at under three
hours.
And, for context, It: Chapter Two clocks in
at 17 minutes shorter than Avengers: Endgame.
Fans flocked to the theaters in droves to
see that film, which has gone on to become
the best-earning movie in history, and largely
found no fault with its substantial length.
It stands to reason that if the biggest superhero
movie of 2019 was super-sized and still performed
that well at the box office, then the biggest
horror movie of 2019 should have no trouble
raking in big bucks regardless of its runtime.
"Can you idiots have taken any longer?"
"Shut up, Richie!"
"Yeah, shut up, Richie!"
It: Chapter Two floats into theaters September
6.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about It: Chapter
Two are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.